director ray thanks for being here thank
you there are a lot of topics we want to
talk about and cover here with you I
want to talk about first foreign
influence in this country the Justice
Department recently indicted a professor
at Harvard for lying about his
relationship with the Chinese government
for people who don't know about China
and what they're trying to do in the US
how much is China doing how much is
China spying in the u.s. bread there's
no country that presents a broader more
comprehensive threat to America's
innovation to our economic security and
to our democratic ideas than China does
just to give you some context for that
just as we're sitting here having this
conversation the FBI has over 2,000
active investigations that trace back to
the government of China 2000 and that's
put a little more context on that that's
about a thirteen hundred percent
increase in terms of economic espionage
investigations with the Chinese Nexus
from about a decade ago which is that
economic espionage how much is it
government espionage well that's the
thing that a lot of people don't really
understand about the Chinese government
this is not about the Chinese people or
Chinese Americans this is about the
Chinese government and the Chinese
Communist Party and they are pursuing a
campaign of intellectual property theft
economic espionage cyber intrusions that
target businesses big and small all
across the country and our academic
research institutions and they do it not
just through traditional government
officials which they certainly do but
also through what we sometimes call
non-traditional collectors which can be
businessmen high-level scientists
high-level academics people like that
all of whom are in different ways
incentivize to steal American innovation
and confidential information and take it
back to China so in the 30s and 40s the
Soviet Union for example had more than
100 spies in the State Department
is espionage a real problem in the u.s.
what is China doing on that front well
traditional espionage is certainly you
know the old sort of spy versus spy
things still very much a phenomenon in
today's world but we're much more
focused in many ways on the economic
espionage which targets American
businesses and hurts American jobs
American consumers and it's everything
from Fortune 100 companies to startups
its agriculture its high-tech its
aviation its healthcare as I said before
it's our academic research system are
they taking an interest in elections
they certainly have a interest in
influencing our our political thought
our policies to try to shift them in a
more friendly Pro China Pro Chinese
Communist Party direction and so
sometimes that gets wrapped up in
election issues is the FBI in charge of
the investigation of the origins of the
corona virus we certainly have a role in
looking into the origins of the corona
virus disclose I would say at this point
there's nothing to add to what the
intelligence community has already said
publicly on that there's still
insufficient information to really know
exactly how the virus emanated from
Luhan when you say that China's active
when there is a crisis for example the
protests after the gorge floor killing
are you seeing foreign intervention to
kind of stir up chaos inside the US we
have certainly seen in the past a
variety of foreign adversaries looking
to amplify controversy in this country
and they use state media they use social
media some of that through propaganda
some of us through disinformation some
of that's they're just fake information
and we are looking carefully at the
prospect of foreign influence or foreign
interference in all of the protest
activity that's occurred over the last
few weeks the president has talked to
the administration has talked about
antiva yet what the Justice Department
and you all have moved on is this
a group that is kind of a right-wing
group that is trying to stir up chaos to
make it look like it's left-wing I
talked to the Attorney General about
this last time we sat down
are there any Antipa investigations
ongoing the violence that occurred
during the protests of the past few
weeks eyes driven by a variety of
different motivations and ideologies
it's not all the work of any single
ideology movement or group we certainly
have a number of active ongoing
investigations into violent anarchist
extremists some of whom self-identify or
otherwise link to the antifoam movement
but I think it's a mistake to try to put
a lot of this into sort of neat
ideological buckets we're really about
the violence not the ideology so the
letter you sent to your FBI family after
the George Floyd killings and what that
means internally what have you been
doing to change the dynamic in the wake
of all of this so I understand
completely that there are a lot of
people out there in this country who are
hurting who are angry who are upset over
instances of racism or where the justice
system has failed people of color in
particularly I would also say though
that the law enforcement family is also
hurting and there are lots and lots and
lots of police officers out there who
are putting their lives on the line
every day who are you know unfairly
tarred by the misconduct of a few so
what we really need is for people to
come together to listen to each other
and to work together to try to figure
out a better way forward when I talk to
the Attorney General he suggested that
there's gonna be some kind of federal
involvement and setting clear standards
for police units across the country I
think there's a general agreement among
police agencies that we need clearer
standards we have to make sure those
standards are claimed to
we have to make sure that there are
systems in place that hold officers
accountable so is that a federal effort
does that suddenly become a federal
training effort I think we're going to
need a strong federal participation in
this effort in helping to set standards
so what does that look like well the
FBI's rule is a few different things
first in terms of accountability we
pursue and have for some time civil
rights color of law investigations where
excessive force violates federal law but
we also participate in doing training
and setting best practices for Police
Department's state local around the
country you know the president said
about these monuments coming down we are
looking at long term jail sentences for
these vandals and the
anarchists and agitators they're bad
people they don't love our country and
they're not taking down our Monument
it's not gonna happen look equal justice
is essential but violence and
destruction of federal property is not
the way to get there and if there are
appropriate basis for federal
investigations we'll pursue what is the
biggest threat you see for a long time
it was radical Islamic terrorism what's
the biggest threat that you see as FBI
director the biggest terrorist threat
here in the u.s. here in the homeland is
what we would call sort of homegrown
violent extremists and these are people
who are lone actors typically motivated
by a variety of different ideologies
some jihadists some others who go very
quickly from radicalization to attack
typically radicalize online and they're
going after soft targets you know
schools shopping malls you know easy to
hit targets and using easily accessible
weapons and those kinds of terrorists
are much harder to detect and prevent in
many ways and so that's what we think of
is that the greatest threat to here in
the homeland
what's the morale here at the FBI I
actually think the morale and the FBI is
quite good our attrition rate is down to
0.4% and they're not a lot of
organizations out there public or
private they can say that now the
investigation into the FISA abuse there
was false information provided to the
FISA Court according to the IG bogus
information about this from a rival
presidential campaign the steal dossier
one of your own top attorneys fabricated
evidence to suggest Carter Page was a
secret Russian asset when in fact he had
helped the u.s. build a case against
Russian operatives there are a lot of
people who look at what has come out and
understanding the dirham report is yet
to come
likely this summer
they wonder will anybody be held
accountable will anything come of this
well first let me say this I think that
IG report describes conduct that I
consider unacceptable a nun
representative of who the FBI is as an
institution and cannot be allowed to
happen again and I've made that very
clear to our workforce now I put in
place an entirely new leadership team
and even though I wasn't director at the
time of of all of this my team and I are
are fiercely committed to making sure we
fix the problems in the past we've
accepted every finding and
recommendation in that IG report but
then gone above and beyond put in place
over 40 corrective measures that enhance
our training strengthen our processes
building more oversight and
accountability and and have referred
employees current employees for
discipline now having said that the most
senior people involved in this activity
in this report are long gone either
terminated some during my tenure or
retired or resides as the FBI disclosed
every piece of evidence related to the
Durham inquiry we've cooperated fully
with the Durham investigation in fact we
even have a lot of people don't know
this we actually have agents assigned to
working on the durham investigation so
we're very much latched up with that
congress says they've have a tough time
getting documents and things from you
senator grassley in particular about the
michael Flynn calls where were you
responsible for holding back from from
Congress some of that stuff I think
we've tried very very hard to be
transparent and cooperative with all the
relevant congressional committees we've
produced all sorts of information and
tried to really lean forward why did it
take so long for the material to come
out for Horowitz you know publicly like
with the FISA the Flynn 302s the reports
it seemed like it took forever why was
that I mean if it wasn't court orders
and the I geez
efforts we wouldn't know anything about
any of this for the IDS efforts we've
been over backwards to be transparent
and cooperative with the IG and he
actually in his report talks about how
fully cooperative and transparent we
were with him the Flynn defense
attorneys Michael Flynn former anis a
national security adviser said they were
not provided the exculpatory evidence
that eventually came out during the
trial they weren't provided who held
that back decisions about producing
documents in a criminal prosecution are
typically handled by the prosecutors I
will say that of course the Flynn
investigation which took place before I
started and then by the time I started
was in the hands of the special counsels
office is something that has in my view
raised serious concerns and questions
which is why I ordered an after-action
review by our Inspection Division to
take a look at whether or not the FBI's
policies and procedures need to be
changed and if there are any current
employees left who may bear any
responsibility for misconduct this
interview happened before the appeals
court decision on the Flynn case siding
with the Justice Department but the FBI
says no matter how it's decided the
after-action review will continue the
president gave an interview in which he
said just the other day what does he
think about this whole process as we
wait for the Durham report and he
characterized it as treason it's treason
look the streets look when I came out a
long time ago I said they've been spying
on my campaign it turned out I was right
what are you looking at what you know
think this is on the crossfire hurricane
matter that's the subject of the IG
report I think it describes conduct that
is unacceptable period full stop and
cannot be allowed to happen and will not
be allowed to happen it but whether it's
criminal not criminal decisions charging
decisions prosecution decisions are not
made by the FBI director those are made
by cross the street at the Justice
tomorrow by prosecutors but somebody
here altered that FISA
report and that would be a criminal
offense right and that individual no
longer works at the FBI and I don't want
to get out in front of the durham
investigation
are you worried what the impact is gonna
be when that all comes out knowing what
you know I think allegations of
misconduct need to be taken seriously I
think there are serious questions that
have been raised here and they need to
be given a serious look and whatever the
impact is the impact is
have you ever one on one gone to the
president the Oval Office and say hey
listen I've this is what I know this is
what the FBI did and here's what it is I
have not met with the president
one-on-one you've not met her ever with
him one-on-one uh and this president has
well publicly said he wants to see the
jury is still out is what he said about
you let's see what happens with him look
the the jury's still out if you don't
meet one-on-one with the president and
he says the jury's still out are you
worried at all about how the president
thinks about you and the job no I think
I have a very professional relationship
with the the president which is I think
what every FBI director and every
president should I've certainly had
plenty of occasions where I've met with
the president just with others there
isn't right you're on senator Graham's
list to testify do you expect to be up
there testifying on in his investigation
I'll see I've testified quite frequently
in this role seems to be a routine part
of the job what's the toughest thing you
deal with every day the sheer volume of
the threats that face this country is
remarkable and so just to give you a
flavor of it you know in the past few
months alone our Joint Terrorism Task
Forces have thwarted potential terrorist
attacks in Tampa in New York in
Cleveland at Kansas City
then you had Kovac come in right and
we've probably got over 400 Co vyd 19
fraud investigations open
we have probably in the last year
something like 1500 kids that the FBI
has recovered or rescued from child
sexual sexual exploitation or
with trafficking we talked about China
before the FBI is opening a new
counterintelligence investigation that
ties back to China every ten hours so
you put some of those thing and that's
just sort of the tip of the iceberg and
your relationship with the Attorney
General the Attorney General and I have
I think an excellent working
relationship
I value him as a friend and a colleague
director ray we appreciate the time
thanks very much thanks Brett